the world of Stargate has so many
Advanced civilizations we have the
Ancients ascended beings the Asgard the
Knox
and there's also another race of aliens
who we didn't really see that much of
within Stargate Universe Planet builders
and with the potential for Stargate to
be returning with a continuation on
everyone's mind could we potentially get
a conclusion
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
the planet Builders are a race of aliens
that were first introduced in Stargate
Universe season one and the episode
entitled faith and essentially what
happened was
the destiny dropped out of FTL
prematurely
the reasoning they gave was that a star
had appeared it wasn't there in
Destiny's logs Destiny had no idea it
existed but it was there when they
dropped out the gravitational well of
this star distorted the fto drive and
essentially they dropped out
before they were supposed to now this
style was very unique in the fact that
it wasn't there when the seed ships had
gone through that that portion of the
Galaxy
it wasn't there there were no planets
there were no stars it should have been
empty space but it wasn't
it appears we have dropped out of FTL
into empty space not planets no stars
nothing ah
check that down
there is however a silver lining
Planet only wanted to saw the systems as
far as I could see
about the same size as Earth
looks close it is
within shuttle range
atmosphere
in the wood
if this star really is this young then
that planet should still be a ball of
molten rock
some testing Rush did some Diagnostics
on Destiny and could find no evidence of
a glitch in the system and determined
that this star as well as the planet had
been placed there after the sea chips
have been in that portion of the Galaxy
sending a shuttle down to the planet
they find a paradise they find fresh
water they find fruit they find
vegetation and medicinal supplies they
find everything that you'd need to start
a new civilization it was perfect it was
a paradise but what they also found was
an obelisk a massive tower that was
constructed by an unknown race of aliens
thank you
[Music]
looks like we weren't the first ones
here
the reason why Destiny had no knowledge
of this star system is that it was
placed there after the gate seeding
ships had passed through a year and told
me they built the star too
that would make them the number one
all-time Advanced civilization it was
surmise that the people who placed the
Obelisk on this planet had also created
the planet itself hence why we call them
the planet builders now this race of
aliens these beings they have an
intelligence beyond anything we've ever
seen in Stargate before the Ancients
even when they were ascended never
created life they never created planets
and never created Stars it's not to say
that they couldn't it's just we never
saw evidence of it so potentially these
are even more advanced than the ascended
beings that we know of as well as
creating an entire planet and a star and
populating it with all the things that
us humans need to survive
they were also able to transport some of
the crew who decided to stay on that
planet back to Destiny yes they ended up
dying because they weren't able to
sustain their life but they were able to
come back to Destiny and Say Goodbye one
minute Destiny only had one shuttle on
its dock the next minute another shuttle
had appeared and all of a sudden
everyone who had stayed on that planet
was back and you have to remember as
well that Destiny had traveled
thousands hundreds of thousands millions
of light years in between where they
were dropped off and where they
reappeared in an instant they came back
an intelligence that can do that can
literally transport someone from one
side of a galaxy to another in an
instant without the use of a Stargate
incredible now you've probably already
watched Jay's video on the update
essentially with penguin in the Parker
Mark Ferguson all godspeed and Stargate
now he mentioned in the video that
during a pitch meeting for Stargate one
of the things Mark Fergus apparently
spoke at length about was Stargate
Universe and having a conclusion to that
but something he wouldn't shut up about
was the planet Builders and having
him be excited about that
points to the fact that it's going to be
a Revival rather than a reboot now a
Revival means a continuation of the
story that we had same characters same
story and just continuing on that Legacy
a reboot is obviously the same universe
but it'd be news stories new characters
Etc
now with Revival this really excites me
the planet Builders are interesting
they are a race of aliens that we know
nothing about and from what it looks
like they are the most advanced race
that has ever existed within Stargate
now obviously we always thought the
ascended beings the Ancients were the
most advanced race that could ever exist
but
there is a potential there that we could
learn more about the universe than we
previously knew
the ascended beings may not be on the
highest plane of existence they could be
multiple layers of existence different
dimensions that life can exist and
interact with our physical plane
we already know that's true from the
ascended plane ascended beings can
interact with the physical plane if they
want to just look at the all right
the Ancients were a little bit more
guarded they didn't want to interact
with the physical plane the only
exception to that would have been people
like omadasala
but who's to say that the ascended plane
is the top level there could be multiple
levels and multiple planes of existence
where even Ascension isn't the final
evolution in the life
basically the idea of having the planet
Builders fully fleshed out and explored
is something that really really excites
me
I absolutely love the idea when I
watched it on Stargate Universe
and I was obviously very very sad when
Stargate Universe ended so the potential
for Stargate Universe Stargate Atlantis
and even potentially Stargate sg1 to
have more stories
is
as a Stargate fan it makes me happy it
makes me incredibly happy
but what do you think are you excited to
potentially see a conclusion to Stargate
Universe and also have the planet
Builders storyline expanded upon so we
can learn more about what's happening in
our own universe
or do you have some other ideas about
what could potentially happen within the
story let me know in the comment section
down below and if you are new to the
YouTube channel make sure you hit
subscribe press the Bell notification so
you don't miss a single video and also
consider becoming a fully fledged side
tracker by hitting the join button down
below
thank you so much for watching and I
will see you next week
[Music]